RALLY IN MICHIGAN, HAVE A GREAT
NIGHT EVERYBODY -- SEE YOU THEN.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," HERE’S A FACT THAT
WILL MAKE YOU BLINK.
WE ARE NOW APPROACHING THE 19TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ARRIVAL OF
AMERICAN TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAN,
THEY ARE STILL THERE DESPITE
REPEATED PROMISES FROM
POLITICIANS ON BOTH SIDES, THEY
AREN’T GOING ANYWHERE AND
AMERICANS ARE STILL DYING THERE.
THAT’S TRUE IN IRAQ TOO, WE HAD
TROOPS THERE FOR 17 YEARS, WHY
ARE THEY THERE?
NO ONE KNOWS OR AT LEAST NO ONE
WILL SAY SO OUT LOUD WITH ANY
CLARITY.
TOO MANY THOUSANDS OF AMERICAN
SERVICEMEN ARE DEPLOYED IN
DOZENS OF COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD AND HAVE BEEN FOR
GENERATIONS.
IN SOME CASES THERE MAY BE A
GOOD REASON THEY ARE THERE, AND
OTHER CASES, WE JUST DON’T TALK
ABOUT IT.
YOU’RE NOT ALLOWED TO.
IN WASHINGTON, MINDLESS
INTERVENTIONISM IS VERY MUCH A
BIPARTISAN PROJECT, BOTH PARTIES
SUPPORT IT.
JUST THE SUMMER, REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS REACHED A RARE MOMENT
OF UNITY, THEY JOIN TOGETHER TO
DEMAND WE KEEP THOUSANDS OF
AMERICAN TROOPS IN GERMANY WHERE
THEY HAVE BEEN FOR 75 YEARS.
WHY SHOULD THEY STAY ANOTHER 75?
PRESUMABLY TO KEEP THE
SOVIET UNION FROM INVADING
HAMBURG.
MAYBE THERE’S ANOTHER REASON, NO
ONE MENTIONED WHAT THAT REASON
MIGHT BE.
THE MORE TROOPS WE SENT OVERSEAS
THE BETTER, THAT IS ONE THING
VIRTUALLY EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON
AGREES ON.
EXCEPT DONALD TRUMP.
TRUMP, WHATEVER YOU THINK OF
HIM, DOES NOT AGREE, HE DOES NOT
BELIEVE THAT AND HE HAS SAID SO
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
HE HAS BEEN TALKING RELENTLESSLY
ABOUT BRINGING THE TROOPS HOME
FROM COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD
AND MAY BE MORE THAN ANY OTHER
SINGLE REASON, TALK LIKE THAT
MAKES OFFICIAL WASHINGTON HATE
DONALD TRUMP.
LAST NIGHT, THE WHITE HOUSE
ANNOUNCED WE ARE FINALLY
BRINGING HOME MANY AMERICAN
SOLDIERS FROM IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN AND YOU WOULD THINK
THERE WOULD BE WIDESPREAD THE
CELEBRATION, FAMILIES UNITED,
AMERICANS OUT OF HARM’S WAY.
VERY FEW IN WASHINGTON ARE
CELEBRATING, THE PRESS CORPS
INCLUDING SOME PEOPLE WHO SHOULD
KNOW BETTER ARE STILL TELLING
YOU HOW MUCH DONALD TRUMP HATES
THE TROOPS AND WANTS THEM TO
DIE, THE GUY WHO’S BRINGING THEM
HOME.
ADD THAT TO THE IRONY FILE WHICH
IS BULGING.
WHAT EXACTLY IS GOING ON HERE?
ONE CLUE COMES FROM THE DEPUTY
ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF DEFENSE.
SHE TESTIFIED BEFORE CONGRESS
DURING THE IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS LAST YEAR AND DURING
THOSE PROCEEDINGS SHE SAID THAT
PENTAGON OFFICIALS BEGAN
RECEIVING "PHONE CALLS FROM
INDUSTRY" IN OTHER WORDS CALLS
FROM PRIVATE COMPANIES THAT
PRODUCE AND SUPPLY WEAPONS AND
MILITARY HARDWARE TO OUR
MILITARY.
AFTER THE WHITE HOUSE PUT A HOLD
ON HIGH-PRICED MILITARY AID ON
THE UKRAINE, WEAPONS
MANUFACTURERS WANTED MORE
WEAPONS FLOWING INTO UKRAINE
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO MAKE
MONEY FROM THE SALE OF THESE
WEAPONS, IT’S NOT COMPLICATED
AND THEY KNEW THEY COULD
PRESSURE THE PENTAGON TO
OVERRIDE A DECISION BY THE
DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT’S WHAT THEY DID.
IF THIS HAPPENS A LOT AND
EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON KNOWS IT.
ON LABOR DAY, THE PRESIDENT
FINALLY SAID THIS OUT LOUD, HE
CALLED OUT THE DEFENSE INDUSTRY
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN DECADES,
WATCH THIS.
>> BIDEN SHIPPED AWAY OUR JOBS,
THROUGH OPEN OUR BORDERS AND
SENT OUR YOUTH TO FIGHT IN THESE
CRAZY ENDLESS WARS, I’M NOT
SAYING THE MILITARY IS IN LOVE
WITH ME -- THE SOLDIERS ARE.
THE TOP PEOPLE IN THE PENTAGON
PROBABLY AREN’T BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO DO NOTHING BUT FIGHT
WARS SO THAT ALL OF THOSE
WONDERFUL COMPANIES THAT MAKE
THE BOMBS AND MAKE THE PLANES
AND EVERYTHING ELSE STAY HAPPY.
>> Tucker: THERE’S A LOT OF
TRUTH IN THAT AND THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES WOULD KNOW.
PRECISELY BECAUSE A LOT OF WHAT
TRUMP SAID IS TRUE, DONALD TRUMP
WAS NOT ALLOWED TO SAY IT OUT
LOUD.
DEMOCRATS IN THE MEDIA WERE
ENRAGED THAT HE SAID THAT.
NEARLY HALF OF SENIOR DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS ARE LINKED
WITH MILITARY CONTRACTORS.
NO ONE EVER SAYS THAT OUT LOUD
AND IF YOU DO, YOU HATE THE
TROOPS -- WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
YOU MIGHT THINK IT’S PURELY
PARTISAN, THAT THIS DISHONESTY
IS A WAY TO GET RID OF TRUMP,
THERE’S NO DOUBT THAT IS PART OF
WHAT IS GOING ON.
THERE IS SOMETHING BIGGER.
DEMOCRATS AND SOME REPUBLICANS
ARE PRIMING THE PUBLIC FOR A
REVIVAL OF INTERVENTIONISM IF
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS ARE
ELECTED.
IF THEY MAKE IT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE, BIDEN AND HARRIS
ARE PLANNING A NEW WAR, THIS ONE
IN THE FAR AWAY AND
STRATEGICALLY IRRELEVANT NATION
OF SYRIA, THEY AREN’T EVEN
TRYING TO HIDE THAT AND THEY
HAVEN’T BEEN FOR A LONG TIME.
BACK IN 2018, WE WERE TOLD WE
NEED TO INTERVENE IN SYRIA
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE
BASHAR AL-ASSAD HAD USED
CHEMICAL WEAPONS AGAINST HIS OWN
PEOPLE.
EVERY CHANNEL TOLD YOU THAT.
THIS SHOW NOTED CORRECTLY THAT
THERE WASN’T ACTUALLY ANY
EVIDENCE THAT HAD HAPPENED,
DESPITE WHAT THEY WERE TELLING
YOU.
THERE WAS A LOT OF LYING GOING
ON AND THAT HAS NEVER BEEN
PROVEN DESPITE WHAT THEY SAY,
BUT THE LEFT DIDN’T EVEN ASK
QUESTIONS.
THEY SWALLOWED THE WHOLE THINGS
HALT THE FIRST DAY, WATCH THE
HYSTERICS ON IT ON MSNBC.
>> IF VLADIMIR PUTIN
MASTERMINDED THE LAST WEEK IN
SYRIA, HE HAS GOTTEN EVERYTHING
HE COULD HAVE ASKED FOR.
THROUGH A SMALL CHEMICAL ATTACK,
NOTHING LIKE THE BIG ONES IN THE
PAST, AND THEN DONALD TRUMP CAN
FIRE SOME MISSILES AT SYRIA THAT
WILL DO NO REAL DAMAGE, THEN THE
AMERICAN NEWS MEDIA WILL CHANGE
THE SUBJECT FROM RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND THE TRUMP TRANSITION AND THE
TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
IT’S PERFECT.
>> Tucker: OH, IT’S PERFECT!
THIS IS LUNACY.
WHO CARES HOW MUCH OF SYRIA
VLADIMIR PUTIN CONTROLS?
GOOD LUCK WITH T THAT.
OF RATIONAL PEOPLE WHO CARE
ABOUT THE UNITED STATES REALIZED
THAT SYRIA WAS A CLASSIC
QUAGMIRE AND THERE WAS NO
OBVIOUS ADVANTAGE FOR US, THE
U.S., AND COMMITTING LARGE
NUMBER OF TROOPS THERE.
WE ARGUED AT THE TIME THAT A
FOREIGN WAR STAGED ON BEHALF OF
THE SYRIAN REBELS, MANY IN FACT
ISLAMIC EXTREMISTS WHO HATE OUR
COUNTRY IS UNWISE, THE PRESIDENT
SETTLED ON FIRING ROCKETS INTO
SYRIA AND BUREAUCRATIC TAPEWORMS
LIKE JOHN BOLTON WERE FURIOUS.
HE CLAIMED THE ABSENCE OF A
TOTAL ALL-OUT WAR WAS PERSONAL
CRISIS.
LATER, THE PRESIDENT SAID WE
WERE PULLING ENTIRELY OUT OF
SYRIA, HE CALLED SYRIA A LAND OF
SAND AND DEATH.
THE SYRIAN CIVIL WAR IS STILL
ONGOING AND FOR WAR PURVEYORS
LIKE JOHN BOLTON AND OTHER
LIBERALS, IT’S STILL AN
OPPORTUNITY.
AT A FUND-RAISER THIS SUMMER,
JOE BIDEN DECLARED THAT THE
PRESIDENT’S APPROACH TO SYRIA IS
NOT ENOUGH, CRIPPLING SANCTIONS
AREN’T ENOUGH BIDEN SAID, WE
NEED TO ESCALATE IN SYRIA.
YOU’VE SEEN THIS LOGIC BEFORE,
WE SOUGHT IN IRAQ, THAT WAS
BIPARTISAN, JOE BIDEN SUPPORTED
THE IRAQ WAR.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT IT BY A
VETERAN, HE USED THE TRAGIC
DEATH OF HIS SON FROM CANCER AS
A SHIELD FROM THE QUESTION,
WATCH.
>> Tucker: THIS MOMENT IS
BEWILDERING TO PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN’T FOLLOWED THE SHIFT IN
AMERICAN POLITICS OVER THE LAST
30 YEARS, LIBERALS USED TO SAY
THEY WERE AGAINST WAR AND GIVE
PEACE A CHANCE, REMEMBER THAT?
JOE BIDEN’S UNQUESTIONING
SUPPORT FOR WARS, WARS THAT
DON’T HELP THIS COUNTRY AT ALL
IS ONE OF HIS CHIEF
QUALIFICATIONS AS A DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE.
IN MAY, HIS POLICY ADVISOR
CONFIRMED THAT HIS
ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE EAGER TO
GET THE UNITED STATES INTO A WAR
IN SYRIA, HE DESCRIBED AMERICAN
TROOPS IN SYRIA, THAT WOULD BE
AMERICANS RISKING THEIR LIVES AS
A FORM OF LEVERAGE.
LINCOLN VOWED THAT JOE BIDEN
WOULD RETURN TO SYRIA IN FORCE
IF HE WINS IN NOVEMBER.
>> TO THE EXTENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS ANY REMAINING
LEVERAGE IN SYRIA TO TRY TO
EFFECTUATE SOME POSITIVE
OUTCOME -- UNFORTUNATELY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS MORE OR
LESS UPON THAT UP TOO.
PULLING OUT ENTIRELY.
IN SYRIA.
HE HAS TAKEN AWAY SIGNIFICANT
LEVERAGE.
>> Tucker: LEVERAGE FOR WHAT?
HOW DOES THIS HELP US?
NOBODY EVER ANSWERS THE SIMPLEST
OF ALL QUESTIONS, THE MOST
PROFOUND, THE ONLY QUESTION THAT
MATTERS.
HE ADDED IT IS IMPOSSIBLE FOR
HIM TO IMAGINE A BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION NORMALIZING
RELATIONS WITH BASHAR AL-ASSAD’S
GOVERNMENT, HE DIDN’T ADDRESS
HOW SANCTIONING SYRIA HELPS THE
UNITED STATES COME IT’S NOT THE
POINT, IT’S NEVER THE POINT.
JOHN KERRY MADE THE POINT ON
MSNBC THAT NOBODY LOVES THE
TROOPS MORE THAN JOHN KERRY
DOES, THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
MAY HAVE LIED ABOUT PLANS TO
WITHDRAW FROM AFGHANISTAN AND
DIDN’T AND TURN THE NATION OF
LIBYA INTO A HEALTH SCAPE OF
CIVIL WAR AND SLAVERY.
TRUST ME, SAYS JOHN KERRY, I
LOVE THE TROOPS.
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
NOT PROTECTING OUR TROOPS, NOT
PROTECTING THE INTEREST OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, THESE
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN ARE
EXTRAORDINARY IN TODAY’S
GENERATION, THEY SERVE
WILLINGLY, THEY ARE VOLUNTEERS
AND THEY DESERVE THE RESPECT OF
THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF IF NOT
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN.
>> Tucker: SO JOHN KERRY
RESPECTS OUR TROOPS SO MUCH BUT
HE WOULD LIKE TO SEND THEM TO
COUNTRIES YOU CAN’T FIND ON A
MAP, PUT THEM IN PLACES THEY MAY
DIE FOR PURPOSES THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY OR THE ADVANCEMENT OF
AMERICAN INTERESTS ONLY TO
SUPPORT CRUMBLING POSTWAR
INTERNATIONAL INSTITUTIONS THAT
EVERYONE KNOWS IS A JOKE AND ARE
GOING AWAY, THAT’S JOHN KERRY
THAT SHE RESPECTS OUR TROOPS.
IT WAS JUST LAST MONTH THAT
CARRIE WHO CARES ABOUT THE TRUTH
TOOK THE STAGE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL CONVENTION AND LONGED
FOR THE DAYS THAT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF OUR SOLDIERS DIED
IN WORLD WAR II.
>> THE ONLY THING EXCEPTIONAL
ABOUT THE INCOHERENT TRUMP OF
FOREIGN POLICY AS IT HAS MADE
OUR NATION MORE ISOLATED THAN
EVER BEFORE.
ON JUNE 6TH 1944, YOUNG
AMERICANS GAVE THEIR LIVES ON
THE BEACHES OF NORMANDY TO
LIBERATE THE WORLD FROM TYRANNY.
OUT OF THE ASHES OF THAT WAR, WE
MADE PEACE AND REBUILT THE WORLD
WORLD.
THAT WAS AND REMAINS
EXCEPTIONAL.
IT IS THE OPPOSITE OF EVERYTHING
DONALD TRUMP STANDS FOR.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS THE GOLDEN
BOOKS FIRST WORLD WAR II, CLICHE
PILED UP ON CLICHE, MINDLESS.
IT’S PROPAGANDA AND DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS ARE STARTING TO BELIEVE
IT.
ONE POLL SHOWS AMONG PEOPLE WHO
VOTED FOR HILLARY CLINTON IN
2016, JUST 26% NOW SUPPORT
WITHDRAWING TROOPS FROM SYRIA.
IF POLLSTERS DIDN’T ASK WHY THEY
SHOULD STAY BUT ALMOST NO
DEMOCRATS ARE FOR PULLING THEM
OUT.
IN CONTRAST, NEARLY 60% OPPOSED
PULLING OUT.
TRUMP VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY
SUPPORT WITHDRAWING FROM SYRIA,
WANTED THEM HOME INSTEAD OF